E aí
[Música]
se você já parou para pensar que quando
a gente cuida a gente se torna
importante para as pessoas aos tempos
atrás eu estava no aeroporto fui fazer
uma viagem a trabalho quando eu cheguei
no saguão do aeroporto lá eu percebi uma
mãe e com uma criança no colo e a
criança chorava muito e a preocupação da
mãe eu percebi que não era em relação a
criança chorar mas sim o que que as
pessoas estariam imaginando naquele
momento foi quando essa mãe então entrou
na fila eu
coincidente mente entrei atrás dela e
mais coincidência ainda foi no momento e
que nós nos sentamos e eu sentei ao lado
desta mãe
o momento em que o avião então começou a
taxiar na pista levantou o voo aquela
criança ela não parava de chorar e
quando de repente o inesperado aconteceu
aquela criança vomitou
bom e ali perceber então o nervosismo na
mãe tudo que eu falava para ela naquele
momento calma peguei obviamente aquele
está aqui e fica na frente na poltrona
do avião coloquei para ajudar a mãe
quando eu olhei para o lado de uma
pessoa olhando para mim essa pessoa com
os olhos arregalados
e de repente eu foquei na situação
ajudando a mãe tirei mamadeira e tirei
ali da sacola lá uma garrafinha de água
e tirei uma fralda e quando olhei para
pessoa que tava do lado da pessoa que
estava de olhos fechados aquele momento
eu pensei a missão é minha
o E ajudando a mãe a minha mãe desespero
até que aeronave Então se posicionou
o e aeromoça veio até a mãe disse para
ela assim olha fica tranquila porque
isso acontece isso é comum e ali então
e a mãe molhar de gratidão ela com a
fila filha no colo ela dizia assim Olha
filha olha titio o titio ajudou a gente
olha filha fala brincando com titio mas
a menina nem falava
e ali e mais uma vez a cada cinco
minutos Olha filha olha titio fala
Obrigada para te ligar menino falar mas
eu percebi aqui tudo isso é que ela
estava me considerando a importância uma
pessoa importante naquele momento
e ali o avião então desceu
bom e quando ela foi embora animais uma
vez ela com a criança no colo ela fez
questão Muito obrigado muito obrigado
por tudo e ela aí ela foi saindo eu
peguei a minha bagagem enquanto eu ia
saindo
aeromoça Sou Eu para mim falou assim
você não era parente deve estar possa eu
falei não só Nossa até pensei que você
fosse o pai eu fui meu não eu te amo
Oi gente que que aconteceu naquele
momento naquele momento eram moça Claro
ela me parabenizou ou pela ação mas
aquele momento que aconteceu nada mais
nada menos que eu cuidei daquela pessoa
e sabe do melhor é que pelas pela mãe eu
fui uma pessoa que cuidei eu fui uma
pessoa importante para criança eu fui
uma pessoa importante e para as pessoas
que estavam naquela aeronave e para
comissária de bordo eu também fui uma
pessoa importante mas sabe que eu senti
naquele momento eu senti do fundo da
minha alma que quanto mais a gente cuida
mas a gente se dou mais feliz quem sente
somos nós ao
longo da minha jornada como palestrante
e professora sempre fui entusiasta da
humanização tanto é que quando comecei a
estudar o tema há muitos anos atrás a
humanização era era dita de uma forma
bem simplificada
e a humanização se falava muito do
mercado da Saúde até que passou
e passou se os tempos e organização
ficou forte também no mundo corporativo
inclusive Hoje Tem empresas que
são destacadas são empresas que têm a
humanização como um valor
percebido Mas uma coisa me incomodava
muito porque essa tal palavra ela é
subjetiva se você for procurar saber o
que que é humanização você vai encontrar
que o efeito se tornar Benévolo afável
sociável mas a minha preocupação é além
de tudo que essa palavra começou a se
tornar o tema Mogi budista na gestão
como os demais termos que a gente sempre
hoje
o e Dori então eu comecei foi no momento
da pandemia e eu comecei a perceber o
quanto os clientes as pessoas me ligaram
e começar então
ficar me procurar por conta aqui a
partir desse momento eu quero treinar a
minha equipe eu quero fazer com que as
pessoas cuidem umas mais as outras eu
quero fazer é que os meus clientes se
tornem cuidados e eu percebia que era
uma
era uma cidade muito grande das empresas
e tem um profissional que fizesse isso
mas uma coisa eu me preocupei no momento
porque humanização não é um círculo que
você monta do dia para noite
e não é assim que funciona
bom e ali então com os pés no chão eu
pensava
como é que nós podemos colocar essa tal
de humanização e prática Poxa já que as
pessoas me reconhece vou trabalhar
humanização e foi aí que eu criei um
método um método que
nossa Podemos sim colocar através de 6
habilidades a humanização na prática
chamado método cuidar a primeira palavra
ela é uma sequência de palavras e este
método vocês vão entender aqui cada
letra tá ali é a letra do cuidar eu
tenho a primeira habilidade que a
compreensão segundo União terceira
interação quarta doação quinta atenção
plena e a última que a respeito eu quero
chamar sua atenção porque uma letra
conecta com a outra existe uma lógica Ou
seja eu não consigo trabalhar
a união sem a trabalhar compreensão eu
não consigo trabalhar interação sem a
trabalhar a união e compreensão e assim
sucessivamente Agora vamos começar com a
primeira etapa do cuidar que é
compreensão compreensão significa que
antes de cuidar do outro gente precisa
compreender como Vamos cuidar da gente e
trago mais uma referência acredito que a
maioria que está aqui já viajou de avião
e nessa viagem como é feito de segurança
você percebe lá que a comissária de
bordo Então coloca suas palavras de
segurança devendo em caso de
despressurização Isso é para te
tranquilizar em caso de despressurização
vai cair as máscaras de oxigênio coloque
primeiro em você para depois colocar a
pessoa do lado
Tô fazendo uma analogia com a situação
infelizmente não é o que nós fazemos na
vida porque nós sempre queremos colocar
a máscara na pessoa que está do lado e
de que forma julgando a pessoa baseado
no nosso mapa de mundo e baseado na
nossa percepção Além disso Quantas vezes
você já julgou alguém ou apontou o dedo
para alguém ou mesmo em várias com
várias situações a gente se torna Beach
mista ou seja uma vítima daquela
situação
gente é comum isso acontece comigo
acontece com você nós somos seres
humanos
e a inteligência relacional
é certa vez eu aprendi aqui nós vivemos
um conto de fadas queremos que a outra
pessoa seja exatamente aquilo que eu
quero que ela seja
ah e hoje eu quero fazer um ajuste do
comportamento falando e comportamento eu
quero fazer um ajuste aqui para vocês
ter a ciência Ajuste o seu comportamento
com ambiente que você está inserido com
a cultura que você está inserido porque
só Daí você pode passar para a próxima
etapa que é cuidar do outro
e Nesse quesito de cuidar do outro seria
fazer ajustes na relação com as pessoas
ao invés de excluídas eu trago a figura
de uma essa que é muito importante uma
Extra com a sua Batuta ele rege uma
orquestra O Astro naquele momento ele
tem algo que extremamente importante a
sensibilidade de ouvir
sabe quando os instrumentos de repente
aquela orquestra está perfeito aos seus
olhos mas o maestro ele percebe que
existe um instrumento somente um
instrumento ou dois instrumentos que
está desafinado naquele momento que que
o Mestre faz ele para a orquestra
e pede por favor corda me
Ajusta a corda me desse instrumento
Ajusta a paleta desse saxofone é dessa
forma que ele é assim ele acaba
retomando então nós temos uma orquestra
ressonante fazendo uma analogia com
nossos dias hoje
e infelizmente não é assim que nós
Agimos Ou seja hoje eu vou deixar uma
dica para vocês vamos ser maestros vamos
vamos nos espelhar no Maestro porque o
maestro no jeito dele ser
sensibilidade auditiva Nós também temos
que ter essa sensibilidade para ouvir
mais as pessoas e tem uma coisa bonita
do maestro ele não tira ninguém ele não
exclui ninguém ele não manda ninguém
embora e algo que nós temos que pensar
também
e de fato quando você se torna uma
pessoa
e humanizada uma coisa que eu gosto de
colocar é o tal do Raptor a porta quando
você entra no mapa de mundo de uma
pessoa e faz com que vocês dois ou seja
crie uma mesma sintonia e essa sintonia
nós vamos conseguir nessa próxima etapa
que interagindo com as pessoas
interação significa dar importância para
o outro deixam o indivíduo encantado com
a sua presença
nesta situação eu quero trazer esta
imagem tá vendo aquele magrelo não ali
que ele magrelo não sou eu isso foi
veados de 1997 foi uma festinha aonde na
saída da escola nós saímos fomos para
casa de uma das nossas amigas e ali
então nós nos reunimos sabe qual é a
coisa mais gostosa dessa festa ali não
tinha celular ali não tinha nenhum outro
aparelho ali não tinha nada que
atrapalhava
e e e o mais interessante é que eu posso
dizer que eu vivi várias ali nós
interagimos e eu vi várias gerações e
dessa minha vivência em várias gerações
eu cheguei nessa geração aonde quando
você começa a interagir a pessoa fala
não tenho tempo olha não tenho tempo não
posso falar agora cara é tá uma loucura
minha vida ou seja as pessoas acabam se
afastando de você
nesta consequência existe também o meio
digital hoje nós percebemos a mesma
coisa no interação nas redes sociais
percebe-se que as pessoas querem cada
vez mais holofotes elas postam fotos
para ter holofotes e ali então querem
ficar famosa super famosas porém a fama
ela é passageira quando nós falamos em
não existe uma diferença grande entre
você ser famoso e vocês é importante
o importante é um caminho a se trilhar
e começa a pensar o que que você quer
partir de agora ser famoso que
rapidamente Você desce ou ser importante
que é um caminho a ser trilhado e depois
também existe uma outra forma de
interação que através também inclui a
parte digital e a gente percebe por
exemplo os e-mails tempos atrás fazendo
diversos trabalhos empresas É o que eu
mais percebo quando se abre meio da
pessoa as pessoas falam dessa forma me
passa o contato da Ana grato
o ou seja qual o nível de sensibilidade
de uma pessoa dessa 0
e agora vamos olhar um lado positivo da
situação muito bom dia Renata tudo bem
você me pode passar o contato da Ana
para que eu possa sanar as dúvidas dela
um grande abraço
e isso é interação interação requer
habilidade
interação eu acredito para interagir de
uma forma genuína nós precisamos
a partir para doação e doação nada mais
é do que
O que significa
solidariedade mas não significa ter
solidariedade mas sim compreender esse o
meu propósito está congruente com aquilo
que eu faço e quando se fala em
propósito Eu quero trazer uma situação
aqui para vocês quantas pessoas que você
conhece que se diz solidária Sabe aquela
pessoa que ela toma a frente numa
empresa dizendo assim ó nós vamos a
partir de agora fazer uma campanha de
solidariedade só que quando passa do
lado de um amigo passa do lado de uma
pessoa
ela simplesmente não fala bom dia não
fala boa tarde essa é a falsa
solidariedade e aqui nós estamos vivendo
de pessoas e propostas propósito
e eu vou terrogação na vida de muitas
pessoas propósito não é fazer mais
A propósito não é você seu melhor aí
como você perguntar para pessoa que que
é proposta a pessoa te respondi
propósito é você ser um melhor não não
proposta fazer pessoas melhores com
aquilo que você faz aí sim partir do
momento que você tem propósito que você
se doa que você se torna importante
a partir desse momento Então você começa
a pensar eu posso sim prestar mais
atenção nas pessoas e a prestar atenção
das pessoas nada mais é do que o está
presente esse tempo atrás fazendo
a fazer uma visita para o cliente meu
nessa visita ele uma cliente minha já
tinha sido agendado e eu percebi que
quanto mais a conversar e então
explicando o meu trabalho explicando os
meus serviços eu percebi que ela não
prestava atenção
bom e ali então eu comecei a mudar a
estratégia e de que forma fiz isso
partir daquele momento eu comecei a
falar coisas que era importante para ela
eu comecei então nós começamos um com
uma conexão e eu comecei a me interessar
pelo serviço dela comecei interessar
pelos produtos dela a partir daquele
momento eu ganhei atenção da pessoa sabe
por quê Por causa de uma frase que diz
assim é aquilo que me convém e nós somos
assim gente por incrível que pareça
Quantas vezes você conversa com uma
pessoa
e na da seguinte forma você conversando
ao invés de prestar atenção na pessoa
você está pensando que eu vou responder
para ela
e nessa situação você deixa de prestar
atenção e aí existe uma etapa aqui é
fantástico em todo esse processo uma das
etapas da humanização que eu mais admiro
que é o r do respeito e o respeito está
relacionado a lidar com diferentes
opiniões respeitando a individualidade o
ponto de vista de cada pessoa sabe de
uma coisa
e da pandemia eu imaginei eu como um
grande entusiasta da humanização eu
imaginava que as pessoas seriam mais
cuidadosas que as pessoas se conectarem
o mais com pessoas eu imaginei que
e elas mesmo carente ela seja diferença
mas não foi o que aconteceu caiu o muro
na nossa frente e nessa queda desse muro
depois de muito tempo a gente percebeu o
quanto as pessoas ainda continuaram com
as suas arrogâncias com as suas pré
potências ou seja colocando inclusive as
suas ideias como verdade e aí gente
pessoas querem provar infelizmente uma
certeza que elas mesmas ainda não têm e
tem uma história
e tem uma história que tinha dois jovens
esses dois jovens e repente vira um
pássaro doente num canto olharão para
aquele pássaro olhou pro outro eu tive
uma ideia
e nós pegamos esse pássaro vamos até o
líder Sábio e vamos perguntando os
preços sábio se passa no está vivo ou se
se passa está morto
é só que nós escondemos o pássaro se ele
falou que está vivo a gente aperta o
pássaro e mata e mostra para ele que o
pássaro estava morto se ele fala que eu
passar está morto a gente coloca em cima
de uma mesa mesmo machucado e diz para
ele que eu pássaro está vivo
e ali naquele momento o jovem se
Perguntaram para o sábio que esse
pássaro que está nas minhas mãos ele
está vivo ou ele está morto
o sábio respirou e disse assim eu não
sei a resposta está nas suas mãos e aí
gente o pássaro machucado representa as
pessoas mais sensíveis e carentes de
afeto os meninos são os nossos orgulhos
os nossos egos e muitas vezes as nossas
Soberbo e o sábio é a nossa decisão de
fazer a partir de hoje tudo de um jeito
diferente Muito obrigado
[Música]
E aí